five unelected Labour and liberal Lords
have defeated a financial matter passed
by the elected House of Commons and
David Cameron and I are clear that this
raises constitutional issues that need
to be dealt with
however it has happened and now we must
address the consequences of that I said
I would listen and that's precisely what
I intend to do I believe we can achieve
the same goal of reforming tax credits
saving the money we need to save to
secure our economy while at the same
time helping in the transition that is
what I intend to do at the Autumn
Statement I'm determined to deliver that
lower welfare higher wage economy that
we were elected to deliver and the
British people want to see you've had a
very clear message tonight about the
need to do something quite drastic
potentially what will your transitional
measures be and you've talked very
strongly about the House of Lords will
you take action against them to punish
them well let's be clear unelected
Labour and liberal Lords who voted down
a matter passed by the elected House of
Commons that raises constitutional
issues and David Cameron and I are clear
they will need to be dealt with well you
will see the approach we will take on
tax credits I said I would listen to the
concerns that have been raised and
that's precisely what I will do I think
we can achieve the same goal of
reforming these tax credits securing the
money we need to ensure our economy is
safe and at the same time helping in the
transition to these changes and I will
set out how we achieve that at the
Autumn Statement because we were elected
to deliver this lower welfare higher
wage economy and that is precisely what
we're going to do you also said this was
a judgement call
and it was your judgment and it's hard
out to be wrong that's damaging for you
isn't it well let's be clear Labor and
Liberal lords were not elected have
voted against measures in a conservative
budget and that raises constitutional
issues I think what people want to know
is how we're going to approach the tax
credits issue I said I would listen and
we are going to listen to the concerns
that have been raised and I set out the
approach we'll take so thank
thank you